[Music]
you have to hear SATs are you here
somewhere
where's Santa you see sitting around hey
hey how's it going okay it's going
pretty good is there anything you'd like
to share with us Santa no I'm good see
you later no no no I'm sure there's some
secrets you want to get off your chest
huh uh well actually there is one thing
but it's kind of embarrassing okay I
don't put out milk and cookies for me I
steal one thing from your living room
something good and oh every year I skip
one city
sorry Rochester oh also uh most of my
elves are just kids I dress up as elves
so I can get around child labor laws oh
my god pretty disturbing okay Conan
Conan yes Santa yeah one more thing I'm
actually not fat that's just a bunch of
cocaine strapped to my belly I I work
for some very dangerous men okay that's
thank you oh also Rudolph's nose yeah it
only turns red when you massage his
prostate okay that's enough also uh mrs.
Claus it's actually just a beanbag chair
with a hole cut in guess what the hole
is for I'm not gonna get not gonna get
yeah I have sex with the beanbag I also
pooped on Jimmy
[Applause]
yeah
you